while we hit a couple wedges before you
get into the driver I mean you're just
gonna hit that what you do just a couple
chips and then just go right in go right
for the drug that's it that's all the
weakness that's my weakness Justin your
only weakness only weakness you gotta be
the best golfer in the world hmm that's
the one I want an 18 right there that's
exactly right what do you what are you
doing you have to hit in the fairway if
it's like you have a shot like a go-to
shot I'll have a go to suck well there's
our problem right there
by the way you put on a little weight
since you played basketball from what I
saw in that documentary retirements been
good time has been good to me yeah I
hesitated then
let's see that's a first shot to a bar
right there get low let it go all we
need you see that 10 out there yeah I
would just kind of take it at the right
you know right at that you got a little
wind off the left but everything on that
left side kind of feeds down there so I
got faith in you Chuck okay pick out a
target taking for deep breath
you suck we're in play
see how it's all from the drought to the
rain yeah so what's the what's the
difference in thoughts or what's the
what's the feelings there I wish I knew
yeah that's all confidence like I'm not
even thinking about that
what less is always more in golf I know
I usually would not be pulling for an
Auburn guy but I'm making an exception
here for you I appreciate that
that's 222 the middle there so every
land up since we got all the water on
the right to see I mean okay when you're
shooting a damn free-throw did you look
at all the places you can miss it or
look at the places that you could make
it I think we should lay up I think we
should lay up let's be positive okay
just lay it up Chuck you just got to
make bogey
all right
look at that if you just would have done
that with the three or five would you'd
have had about a 12-footer for birdie
hey man I'm not that confident see
that's okay we're gaining on it we're
getting closer every shot I like it
that's good swing on it Chuck yeah small
target
get up a little bit go
all right let's I want to hear I've been
hearing about this pudding we're gonna
see it right here well you go I must
introduce you to my putter yeah I caught
my part of the machine you're gonna get
to see the machine in action I want to
see it in action greens are nice Oh
perfect ring true role to them
how are your reading greens oh I'm
pretty good at putting I ain't gonna lie
yeah do you want me to just stay out of
your way then no I want you to help me
out okay okay all right let's see this
machine work
easy easy easy easy easy
that was a good line got this putt for
all the marbles right here I love this
that's a big hole Chuck not get in there
stay up stay up Donna dang I wanted that
too I wanted it to oh man
thought you had a Chuck I did sorry man
I'm sorry
come on machine come on man
you